nous allons élire nos conseillers des
français de l'étranger le 30 mai
prochain le 29 en amérique et un peu
avant à partir du 26 par internet
c'est un scrutin qui a lieu dans cent
trente trois circonscriptions
vous avez trois dates importantes à
retenir donc deux en plus des élections
c'est la date du 26 avril pour vous
inscrire et vérifier que vous êtes bien
inscrit sur votre liste consulaires
électorale donc vous allez au consulat
dont vous dépendez vous vérifier que
vous êtes bien sur la liste et vous avez
jusqu'au 30 avril une semaine après pour
vérifier que le mail kate inscrits au
consulat et le téléphone portable qui
est inscrit au consulat sont les bons
parce que sinon vous ne pourrez pas
voter par internet ce qui dans certains
pays sera absolument indispensable vu la
situation sanitaire
les conseillers consulaires ce sont les
élus locaux des communautés françaises
qui sont installés à l'étranger y en a à
peu près un élu local pour 3000 français
à l'étranger dont il ya des très grosses
communautés comme à londres à genève à
bruxelles
et puis il ya des toutes petites
communautés comme à zagreb dans ma
circonscription où il n'y a qu'un élu
nous avons 522 lycées français à
l'étranger est évidemment un des rôles
importants d
des conseillers des français à
l'étranger c'est de participer à la
gestion de ces lycées français et
surtout ce sont eux qui affecte les
bourses pour aider en fonction des
situations personnelles pour aider les
familles françaises accéder quelle que
soit leur situation financière et de
revenus à pouvoir mettre leurs enfants
au lycée français 6 en 1 dans la dans la
ville où ils habitent
c'est pas parce qu'on habite à
l'étranger que des fois on est on se
sent un peu loin qu'on se sent un peu
oublié ce n'est pas vrai d'une part et
d'autre part la france a besoin de nous
donc il faut voter nous depuis trois ans
qu'on est ici on a transformé le regard
que nos collègues à l'assemblée porte
sur les français à l'étranger il faut
aller voter il faut montrer qu'on
s'intéresse il faut montrer que cette
citoyenneté elle est présente
moi je le sais elle est très présente
dans nos communautés les gens veulent
s'engager
donc il faut absolument vous organisez
vous organisez ne pas laisser passer les
dates et il faut que cette élection
marque ce que nous avons fait depuis
trois ans dans la fonction dans la
réforme de cette communauté dans la
réforme des institutions des français à
l'étranger pour que vraiment on marque
que nous sommes à l'étranger mais nous
sommes 100% français